what's up guys welcome to GameSpot's
things you missed the show brought to
you by kind of funny that's us hanged
him gettys this is great miller high
today we're taking a look at the Suicide
Squad the second trailer second trailer
right there was a teaser this is the
trailer 1 I think this trailer 1 no no
this is trailer to trailer this is the
thing a lot of people are gonna if
you've never seen one of these things
you must never seen one me talk about DC
Comics we're about to go into the [ __ ]
ered zone here and get really really
deep into it so what you need to know is
that I'm gonna be pulling a whole bunch
of stuff from trailer 1 so if you want
to open up two trailers and a separate
tabs I support this because you're a lot
of stuff I've been looking at the
analysis of trailer 2 people aren't
pulling in enough stuff from trailer 1
to make the connections in gotcha gotcha
now here's the thing Greg usually with
this series I'm kind of the one dropping
the knowledge yeah but here obviously
you mr. DC fan boy himself Greg Miller
yeah you're about to get into it let's
do this ok cool queen of course of
course right so now if you already stop
it stop sobbing you're going too fast
earlier we're going into this prison
penitentiary thing here right now
obviously everyone's jumping to
conclusion which I agree with that it's
Belle Reve Belle Reve of course home
it's like them it's the down in
Louisiana and DC Comics right it's home
of all the metahuman bad bad criminals
and it is where Task Force X / the shoes
that's what usually is run out of so
that's where we're jumping to and they
also have coming up you'll see on night
and let go so of course the guy yelling
in there uh-huh Jai Courtney yes aka
Captain Boomerang let it go now where
you roll into Harley now of course
hardly drink espresso reading a romance
novel which is now what it's hard to see
right there but if you see on her leg
it's a sight Bravo detainee we're about
to see Deadshot will smith and you'll
see it really big and boldin on his back
there again I think they're calling such
you know site Bravo being bellerive or
whatever and I like the detainee thing
cuz it's like one time obey its kind of
giving us you know that the government
look of what it is right on what's going
on there outside of the justice system
they're over here of course yes
there we go Will Smith looking and he's
upset he wants out he wants to get back
to his daughter again from trailer one
we know that floyd lawton has his
daughter stop killer croc doing push-ups
here he's got his own little pool very
arkham asylum st yeah you know i mean
from the games we know or whatever
things you gotta keep it pumped you know
sure he's got all his meat hanging over
there and stuff because he's cannibal in
a monster on stop el Diablo here now
here's there's a lot of things I want to
talk to you about ladies and gentlemen
happening the Suicide Squad trailer a
lot of different themes elements and so
that's where it's gonna be crowded along
el Diablo here of course making fire out
of his hand so he's a Pyromancer right
there here's what I want you to know
about suicide squad based on this
trailer based on what i think i think
that Suicide Squad is going to be as
they are now expanding the Cinematic
Universe for the DC this will be the
first movie where they really introduce
magic and they're like magic is real in
this universe I don't think Batman
Superman I'll talk about too much it all
comes down to how they're gonna use
Wonder Woman we watched the DC Comics
thing last night on CW and they talked
about you know that that mascara is the
deal they were there to protect man
they've given up a man so are they gonna
play into the gods and like is it going
to be magic there as well who knows but
I think suicide squads give me a first
taste of real magic and as I will talk
about in a second and we get going I
think it's also gonna be anchored or not
hardly I think we're gonna see Harley is
going to be our gateway to this akeem
bro ok well the speaking of that the
crock dude right what's the deal with
that yeah it Batman he's a Batman
villain he's been around forever you
know is it's one of those where his
interpretations always a little bit
different in terms of jerseys I mean
he's Whalen his name was Waylon righty
who goes on becomes a crock at some
point of skin gets scaly we all know
from the animated series where they
played up but he's like super crocodiles
yeah I don't know how exactly they're
gonna play it on the eats people he does
eat people yet circus freak kind of
thing every stop here now I did not
realize captain boomerang was being
played by fun houses Adam Kovac is very
very very accurate he wants to get out
obviously now I'm telling you this right
now Greg Captain Boomerang yeah he's
gonna be the star breakout star are you
basing that on the one beer thing I'm
later on oil there's multiple things
every single time you see this guy in
this Chandler he's just oozing with
character this you're going on every
motion just feels right right I
I think he's going to be the equivalent
of Batista in guardians of the galaxy oh
the moments he has are the ones that
people are sure okay I like that on see
it's interesting cuz I'm I was thinking
the fact that you know Killer Croc could
have like the Holcomb omens Amanda
Waller of course I haven't really
explained Suicide Squad if you're
watching this I assume you know a bit
about it but Amanda Waller this
government agent right sets up Task
Force X the Suicide Squad based on all
these super villains or whatever right
we're basically there's usually
something implanted their head that they
can like a kill switch they can blow up
their mother heads off right away or
whatever if they don't do what they want
send a min on missions that you know
nobody else would want to go on school
they don't care if they die or not now
can you frame by frame are you aware of
the frame but I am this is something
that gets glossed over but this is a
nice little effect here right as they go
into both this logo and then the next
logo they go in there put like the Joker
riding or whatever the hell is going to
be so the pops up that your pictures and
then it let it go into the next one too
there you go they do to comment call me
who yeah I like that rook I mean but
even then though just the colors and the
video is and the brightness of this and
just the kind of like garnish look that
it has like very unlike anything we've
seen from DC right will be so far is
this is like I i don't i know we work
with a jerk when I I I know a jerk I
know I I know this guy named Colin any
always throws around this hashtag Colin
was right and stuff last night was a
greg was right moment cuz i've been
saying for a long time Suicide Squad has
the chance to be the breakout suicide
squads gonna catch her off guard
da-da-da-da-da and last night everybody
was talking on how great it was amazing
was and this is gonna be a little bit so
much let more light and does about my is
what I've been predicting also you
notice before you go y'all like the
harley quinn diamonds oh yeah i'm not a
lot of people call that I don't everyone
off my attention now here we go stop you
got people running in Belle Reve there's
something going on right you'll see the
word shoe pop up a lot mmm and it's mean
that when i see em ERT that's emergency
response team later on you'll see sue
special housing unit again saying that
we're not in the arena these aren't your
normal kind of people we are now stop
this is very important very interesting
you just stop there this is if you look
at this chess what does it say alpha 1
alpha 1 now what's interesting about
alpha 1 is i'd write down his name of
course he's the guy from neighbors he's
not said he's the friend from me we were
to put
I put his name on here alpha one I can't
find his name on here I put it on here
cuz I'd never here is ike brain holds
burn baby burn Reynolds all right Clara
know you're smarter than me alpha one
mm-hmm now a lot of people thought when
he got announced that he was gonna be in
this movie who's gonna be a young Hugo
Strange still could be still could be I
doubt it seems like he's a guard more
than a doctor but you'll seem a few
different times in this trailers usually
being a dick to the Suicide Squad so
he's working on the Amanda Waller Rick
Flagg team on this guard side but
something I want everyone right now at
you listening at home take a mental
picture of his face because he's going
to be important later when I start
setting up my timeline and how I think
this is all tied into its Harley's
origin and then this is a go I think
she's thoughtful I mean okay stop go
back alpha one being a jerk here alpha
one torturing people alpha one when I
first saw this in the trailer in motion
right I was like oh no no we weren't
framed by Framing I thought it might be
will smith yeah it's El Diablo if you
look Scarlett back in the tube he's
being water tortured right he's this
fire guy I can't do is fire stuff play
pokemon you know that's not a good
matchup I guess that is really where we
all learn the fire and water don't mix
but alpha one be the one who's torturing
of course so they have a big problem
with him let it go then here we go now
this is always the thing there's the
shoe I was talking about the back where
I thought maybe it's a guy you she don't
owe ya yeah this is you know through the
editing of trailers you're never a
hundred percent sure what if things are
happening for you ha jali this really
does look like them being introduced to
croc and you would assume that if we're
sticking with the idea of the Suicide
Squad maybe this is them bringing these
are the doctors are gonna implant table
with whatever the kill switch it yeah
don't let it play ok croc comes in be
scary cheerly alpha 1 and again there
now this is a great one at posit go back
two seconds just no fractions of seconds
um its target now so alpha one that your
eyes are drawn to Will Smith cuz you
look away from most of course but alpha
one back there then this is an old guy
in the other corner is looking at
nothing yeah like beyond your job all
right go you won't give me two frames n
now I 34 stop with this is the the
introduction we assume of Captain
Boomerang right yes now this is where
Harley pops out and she's like well the
boys and does the whole awesome there is
land and it seems like they're all being
introduced maybe they're all getting
bellarine for the first time maybe
they're all meeting in bellary for the
first time but what I love about this is
if you notice this would imply that
Captain Boomerang was sent to Belle Reve
in the Australian post it says right
down there Australian post and he was
just mailed in a body bag I love that so
let it go you pop society fight so much
people oh yeah yeah pause michigan shirt
in the back always a big fan when they
let the school's names be in there like
just like the hit movie road house where
they were wearing Missouri sweatshirt
thanks important very important but
Israel talk about with the with captain
boomer oh sure pops out of the bag just
punches the first person right right
right there's no thought in that it on I
love that I love that idea I have a
different read of this where I think
this is like a training facility sure
but I mean I I agree with you on that
but I think this is like a big hero just
well we're gonna go forward a few more
frames I'm gonna see Deadshot you're
gonna see Harley and they're both in the
detainee outfit right but this looks
like the introduced introduction of
boomerang to the group and it looks like
the introduction of slipknot to the
group here let it go there Slipknot
knocks out a woman by the way so they're
like all bets are off yeah he's bad guy
now how much do you know about Slipknot
um they were really popular in the 90s
no one knows anything about slipping on
the other than he's like super low run
DC guy right so the theory for a while
on the internet cuz he's what he is is
like he's an assassin he's also a master
of ropes oh yeah I hope some does have a
lot of reps uh the theory for a while
was of course you will I know you're
you're up on all of your DC knowledge
you watch Batman assault on Arkham
Arkham the awesome animated movie that
was all about suicide squad tighten I
already know it's a really good movie
everybody should do it but in that movie
right they put all the Suicide Squad
they put I don't remember who it was
they put some be Lister in that d-lister
in there and you're like they're gonna
die eyes this guy no I didn't think it
was a cartoon I didn't know there's
gonna be a hardcore cartoon I was like
why is that guy in there and then yeah
the first thing he tries to leave Amanda
Waller blows up his head to make a point
oh yeah okay exactness these movies need
cannon fodder right and i think that
Susan's caught entirely his cannon fun
not everybody but for sure I Slipknot
for sure the ferry on the internet was
like we've never seen him in marketing
materials really we don't see many of
the hero shots he must die in a scene
like this again this looks like the
introduction right where the FBI
jumping him up Australian posted in
boomerang we already got Harley and but
later on he does come up I still think
he dies in this movie ok nice to see ya
here there there you go Harley shoe
pause again dial me back a couple
bellerive up there in the road doorbell
really oh yeah for sure now it is it
says shoe over there so yeah we would
assume they're still in bellary even
that you know the thing here give me a
couple more frames to get back to Rick
Flagg Rick Flagg here of course leader
Suicide Squad he's the one who is still
in the good graces he's the actual
command or part of this now here's where
it gets interesting and where I thought
some people missing the boat even though
there's a lot to talk about I'm insulin
behind him now I can never pronounce her
name Cara Delevingne donde can we get a
reading delavan of course Nick knows
Nick knows everything about me I know
everything about the fictional
characters Nick knows the real people
she's June moon right now she is the one
who becomes in trick enchant chances in
the old cop in the comics right for a
while she could just like make the
person appear and then she would they
switch it was it whatever this will see
in it takes over now here's where you
need to take some of that trailer 1
knowledge and toss it in first off again
through the editing of trailers maybe
we're slicing their own conversations
but Rick Flagg appears in the vo that's
going right now to be talking to her
because he says you're possessed by a
witch he but everyone else is like
shoots people eats people crazy you
possess by which now if you go back to
trailer number one we had the whole
thing of June moon seemingly before Inge
she's in chantress going down into a
cave going in had some kind of mutters
slime on her face that will be important
later on in this trailer I assume you've
already seen this tralian or I'm going
with this but are we important later on
right here she's not part of this she
doesn't is she she's possessed they know
is it in a context issue keep its
interests okay I want you all to keep
your eye on the train tristan g june one
there you go do some hero shots now
we're getting them in their in their
outfits they're finally better I think
Rock looks awesome don't know about you
it looks right he looks like I told on
El Diablo stop there's so there's an
enchantress right now here's the next
interesting thing to pull from the
internet and put in here there's been
theories that enchantress is actually
the villain of the movie
so now I need you to when you know
through this looking through this
through the looking glass with me here
you won't see June moon working you know
in hero shots you won't see transfers
working with everybody else now stop
here that's important too uh but keeping
it keeping chances on the floor for
anyone die me to back to that sexy beard
ago okay you know what this is no this
is scott eastwood clint eastwood's son
really yes do you know he's playing in
the movie no no one knows who he's
playing in the movie very that's all I
got for you he's there he's good-looking
he's gonna shot shot he's gonna do a
fist bump later on in the trailer and
that's all we'll know so keep going I
want a fist bump Clint Eastwood son
maybe you will one day maybe why I'm on
the show is hope thinking I thought this
hold this whole scene was great looking
we should have in a slipknot okay you're
gonna die do this guy it's been sighs
you getting it over for you toast buddy
there you go flag sitting there the
whole group yeah this is you know but
that's just a great scene for her yeah I
explained in that situation you I so now
stop now this is where we're going into
battle we're doing all these different
things what I like a lot of you wanting
here for you is that this was filmed in
toronto hmm I don't I don't I don't know
Toronto well this seems like an insert
from Chicago usually whenever you see
bridges over water in you know a city
landscape like this it's chicago the
chicago river whatever I'm big Chicago
boy but what's interesting of course is
that we've known for a while that this
is happening in midway city which is the
silver era a silver age home too hawkman
hawkgirl but we've seen you know they've
had police cars with that say yeah
midway city and all these different
things another dog so that's the city
we're fighting and we think right now it
you know it's DC wikipedia says it's
based on chicago so if they actually use
some chicago inserts to make it look
like that makes em a pro i'm not a
promising stop so here's where we start
getting into what we're up against right
so here it looks like a plane in the
background and brought down right I'll
go for it a few more frames now this is
we know slimy right we've got some kind
of slime we got some kind of creature
who got some kind of whatever going on
now it's cut off on our view but the
viewer can see it real well over there
on that dunkin donuts there's graffiti
it's an X and then stuff written around
the X now as you know from the last of
us from zombie movies all these other
things right what
we have been finding recently is that
that is like supposed to be shorthand
for six people were found to a more
infected or some you know some version
of that yeah so now we start wondering
you know there's that thing of you know
dead shot Lannie like time to save the
world da da da da I when I first saw the
trailer and we first started to talk
about suicide squad with the first trail
yeah I was thinking ok cool they're
going after the Joker they're being sent
in to take out the Joker that's the
thing da da da da now it looks like
they're actually up against some kind of
magic zombie threat and this goes back
to what I was talking about that this is
gonna be the movie that induce it
introduces all this stuff in terms of
like this is how magic works in the DC
Universe it is real they have these
things that's always been a bring for me
is a comic book reader and fan that's
always been a breaking point for me I
are alien landing okay guy just as a bat
okay dr. fate going between worlds and
doing all the stuff like all right I
don't know about that right so mean
should see how they explain I'm getting
it you can go back to hating it I liked
any okay all right now there we go so
now the group shot right uh real quick
this is gonna come in later here right
that we will see throughout this these
helicopters getting shot at and where it
will get back to that I just want to
keep that in your mind right now looks
like named The Suicide Squad going down
right one of their choppers now here's
what I'm talking about your right here a
shot it's everybody right no it isn't
we're Slipknot where is in chantress
right yes katanas first real debut in
the trailer awesome cuz she's a really
cool character I'm excited to see what
they do but this was also feeding in
last night when I was you know on my
forums on my reddits and all that stuff
of people saying well there you go proof
slipknot's dead and a lot of people then
were just ignoring that literally the
next faint what France that's about
still there and that's what Jai Courtney
Captain Boomerang is wearing over here
right so it looks like this looks like a
later shot it looks like he's got no hat
it looks like an attack has rendered
Captain Boomerang hatless one thing I
know about captain boomerangs that he's
gonna get it back ah I had to do it
that's he did so here they are marching
in we have katana in the back there
again like she wasn't introduced you
know in the normal thing yeah you know I
mean I wonder if she's joins the team
late here's more of this stuff again
slimy tearing think it looks like you're
fighting prototyper looks like the 1998
Godzilla movie it does writers the
babies yes subway
uh Deadshot shoot something Harley going
away I would love Miley yuck or not that
everyone knows that i mentioned how much
will smith has in this movie he does get
the first billing sure yeah it means
will smith yeah and that's gonna be the
interesting but I do my prediction is
going to be and we haven't even gotten
to that sub thread of this trailer so I
hope you packed a lunch for this is the
fact that this will be Harley's origin
story that's gonna be the anchor for us
is the audience but yeah I think well
smooth I think it's always weird because
Will Smith to me is going to be the
leader of the team really you know what
I mean but then of course they do have
flags so we'll see what there you go ok
Harley doing stuff we can already see
the mask in motion of course we haven't
seen that and I don't think ever but if
you notice here this is them in an
office building right fighting something
here's what you got now some people
theorize these are dudes in costumes
that this I'm saying they're infected
I'm saying what's happening is that
they're there to fight this magic
infection I don't know exactly what's
happening uh some dark matter from the
other world that is turning people into
these warriors or whatever because
there's a scene coming up and I don't
think I'm lucky enough that it's the
next one but it's where it's where that
you know uh Deadshot is firing out of
his awesome hand cannons which he needs
canonically uh against a whole bunch of
people running out of like something but
we'll get there a second I'll so that's
it yeah that's great good job absolute
now ok so now now thanks Cameron now
everybody pack a lunch and get ready so
now here you might remember about 40
minutes ago in this rewind I told you
what you needed to look for and remember
was the facial hair of 1 alpha 1 hmm I
believe this man getting slapped by the
Joker is alpha 1 and so now we get to
the point of where are we in the
timeline if we believe there are many
timelines merging is right right right
here like look that looks like alpha 1
don't tell me that doesn't know unless
my neighbors are sure so now here's
where y'all need to pack a lunch and get
that we're gonna get right in to the
MIDI nerdy Gritty of this what I want to
propose to you is this is that this
movie will open with Joker assaulting
Arkham taking it going in and that's
where he holds on Arkham sounds right
where he will get Harley right
my question for you is is there some
kind of party happening in argument not
like a party part mean like you know
like a dinner you know like they're
having like the Christmas party on the
Christmas party right but alfo one
appears to be in some kind of suit Joker
in a purple collared shirt 40 minutes
from now in this video that will be
important for you we'll go on he has
like ten outfits in Australia I know and
trust me I tried to piece them all
together timeline wise these guys of
course making their assault here we've
seen this before that we've seen these
guys look at everyone connects the
neversoft logo in there and the creepy
Ally McBeal baby grew up to be a gun
slinger over but they're making us in
the is this an assault on Arkham again
is this way yes they're assaulting for
sure you don't I mean and if there it
says Ward F you're thinking or what I
assume it says war deficit r & F
whatever the hell that means but I don't
think warden a word of Arkham you got
the stuff over there it doesn't look
like Belle Reve different kind of set
again though the colors you see the blue
and I don't like glowy colors in this
shirt wholesale I like that so now this
is another one keep in mind this is yet
another joke or outfit to track he's in
the tuxedo a lot of people were not a
lot of people I saw some people outside
online doing a call out of like oh what
a nice homage that famous a famous alex
ross a joker and harley painting where
Joker is in the tuxedo on Harleys in
front of them all sexy like it fit keep
in mind there's shooting at the back of
the plane when is this happening here we
go we wanted this this is mr. frost now
when i first saw this in context him i
was like oh is another one of these army
guys who's out there shooting stuff
doing his thing for Suicide Squad that
we've seen so many of them not at all
when I'm totally wrong on it so if you
said it credit this young man here is
Jim Barack that is a link sure paarl
rock from fury I knew and more as the
guy who was really fat and then got less
fat and dated Jess con true would okay
he will come up later and he's one of
Joker's henchmen if you notice in this
he's wearing he looks like this is the
same thing right there's Joe can you see
over there the tuxedo in the corner but
he's also dressed up like they came from
a ball or something gotcha he says mr.
frost on his arm and then he has some
kind of logo on his patched there it
looks to me like jcf somebody said it
was an ass maybe Joker security force
either way doesn't matter you store you
tell me there's a mr. freeze into mr.
fur
in this DC universe well technically
there is no mr. freeze that we know of
yet what you would have some victories
out there doing something saving Nora of
course now here we go this is a call
back to the original trailer which a lot
of people have forgotten where if you
have it open another tab don't watch it
yet but later go back and watch it and
you'll see that that is where you merge
up iball man and babyface and all these
people running through and shooting cuz
it looked like they were going in to
take over and they you see them throw
Margot Robbie down and she's very
glasses regular hair she's still dr.
Quinzel she's the army and that's when
he walks on which could hurt you right
does that you soon where he starts
birthing arley and making her into what
he wants now of course this is another
thing pulled from the first trailer
where I'm telling you that this is all I
think these are all flashbacks and
that's where I think it comes down to
that we open and we're gonna open this
movie with Harley being dr. Quinzel
she's working in Arkham or whatever and
then doors explode Joker's dudes come in
down and I'm gonna hurt you real bad and
it's a hard cut and we jump weeks months
ahead or whatever to where we'll see it
later where she was doing that sexy
dance or whatever and she's got like the
gold on she's like just doing all this
stuff because we saw that and then
they'll leave that place when Batman
comes to break it up get into the car
that we see cuz this is a car from
trailer one that had Batman on top of it
remember car was another bully as if one
no I remember that one got this one so
these are all flashbacks leading up I
believe we have all these flashbacks
leading up to Harley getting imprisoned
in Belle Reve how she got to be there
maybe they won't all come at once like
I'm saying but that's this is I I still
say for sure flashback where she says he
also my hope you got insurance I'm
really excited for this movie I can tell
Greg okay just letting you know don't
know if you I mean I don't know if you
all are aware that every one of my
dreams has come true and there's DC
cinematic you almost almost exploded
last night watching now here we go
enchantress again right let's have some
fun not with the group appears to be
threatening the White House appears that
she's in a safe room at though I would
say a safe room at the White House right
yeah threatening them so i would say
again maybe she is the bad guy you know
any maybe that's how it worked of that
they set up the squad everything's going
fine and then you know uh June moon gets
overtaken by The Enchantress you possess
we knew for a while but something kicks
in in this term terms of like this is
why magic existence universe is what we
gotta do ya see that
looks really calm well I to be dealing
with this whole thing but my thing is I
think it's one of those where she
stopped time she's frozen everybody like
they're not make their pain again the
inside if their cognitive happening or
she's just there being a goonie yeah I
hate goodies there we go what you're
saying like even right there right yeah
like motion joy I want to hang a guy
great the great scene of Joker come on
in his laugh right his laugh is so long
good next I like all the champagne all
the knives all the good we haven't even
talked about the the music in the
trailer which obviously is amazing i
believe it's an original song I've never
heard of exactly I love the the way that
they they used the music similarly to
guardians of the galaxy judging yeah
everybody's like all or copy I'm like
well I can if you would have listened to
me a long time ago I would have told you
this was gonna be their Guardians that
everything's really cool but I love that
is the way that this trailer was edited
with all of the sounds of gunshots and I
yeah and his flowing totally matching up
with music yeah beautiful okay don't
worry explosions great okay finally we
get to see katana in action right now
now of course I don't wanna screw this
up cuz I always screwed up I was called
the other thing soul taker that's her
blade right everybody she kills the soul
goes into it and that's why if you
notice here in this freeze frame there's
all these skulls coming off of it mm-hmm
cuz those are the souls trapped inside
it later on her eyes are gonna go black
and I just want to tell you about it she
has the ability to communicate with
everyone in she's ever killed her best
so you imagine that's what she's doing
she's going into talking to one of the
people who's passed away but who knows
excited to see more of her right there
you see it if you were wondering if i
was making it up about it being midway
city it says midway city police on the
car there there'll be a couple other
shots of it too uh Amanda Waller in the
background watch during this is like
obviously gonna be I think gonna be
obviously the montage yeah like you're
all together and we're to see if you can
pack it with the suicides good and I get
all do this Deadshot oh come on be
awesome El Diablo's gonna be mad of
course I'd be mad at my faces tax you
like the food this that's just a great
scene right okay so that's what i was
talking about right with her eyes going
black I assume she's going to
communicate with somebody she's killed
before this is what I was talking about
before where Harley is dancing and her
again Harley Eskow trim right that we've
talked about so many times and then I
think this leads into getting into the
car run away because I assume Batman
comes in to break
so yeah in one of the flashbacks uh
assault here this seems to me Joker
forces right mr. frost out there
shooting all this stuff we're shooting
down other planes is he shooting down
are they are they fighting with the
Suicide Squad right there I'm on it's
unclear this is again the assault now
this is where it's interesting right is
like this looks like it's paired up with
the other stuff with the mass and the
babies but this looks like a newspaper
facility not a hospital right it's like
a bottling plant so I don't think it is
there's clinics & Son and the guy who
owe nobody knows and sorry for him now
here's here's the big one Groot oh yeah
exactly no it totally looks like grit
right and like people are like what who
is the enemy here right and entrain
enchantress makes sense in a way but my
thought process on it is going to be
this of course I think in tranches could
be the bad person iving this person
right here who seems to be the big bad
villain for the city sequence could be
just a mini boss yeah i mean this
chantress is like oh that's gonna
certification oh no I screw it I got I
got I got take me back there Timmy why'd
you let me touch it alright it's a thing
oh my god let go like that like I got
like all right so here so this could be
this clearly if you I'm trying to get
you want to lit up frames this looks to
be a normal person right it's got a hand
and it's got its got all this stuff
wrapped around it so maybe this is
another infection you know I mean up
there spreading it and so this it would
be the evil unleashed by Enchantress job
thing that is then infecting the Midway
City which is then making people into
these monsters or whatever maybe it is
the big man of on its own we at which
point if that's the case I think what's
gonna happen is that enchantress and
moon were coexisting fine but then the
magical scales a balance tip to wear
this ancient evil was and so she took
over and she appears to be you know
working against the Suicide Squad when
really she's just out for him game and
be I have to come together to fight
whatever this thing is which does look
like group as it destroys this train now
here we go back to getting everything
together right this looks like the
newspaper plant again I say before again
there's Jessica's boyfriend from True
Blood mr. frost and whatever this guy's
you know goofy ass mask is but this
guy's got a hairnet on no he's in some
kind of facility but this is another
Joker outfit look for you it was just
wearing a lot of
katana and Killer Croc not getting along
you did but I assume that now here this
is literally a frame right but it goes
back to my point of this is I think that
all flashback Margot Robbie is Margot
Robbie as dr. Quinzel I assume this is
during her if I'm if I had if you're
making me predicting you are cuz you're
paying me for this video she running
away from what's happening inside right
runs outside and then this is the
interior interior view of Joker's car
Joker's car rushes up she slams on it
Joker gets out and then or she runs from
Joker and then he comes up and gets it
with the gonna hurt me no real man I
like your ear Joker thank you i'm
working i've been working on he doesn't
really like where he's going with it
again midway city there's but this is
where i was talking about first off
thank you like fanservice right there
like that's what that shot does a lot
shoots out of these little hand cannons
or whatever you want to call them
handguns but here this is where I like
that they're like just waves of bad guys
but it's interesting in the way of like
if they're infected cool but they're not
mindless write this this one's using a
shotgun is here it like there and these
guys have guns but then like you just
take it out and goes over and you don't
even stop its intricacy what these bad
guys we have two more of them they're
affected more guys there you go Groot
now oh yeah I'll tell you I'll tell you
for a second and I do I think this is
the case under no circumstance but I
would say and I don't think it's gonna
happen so don't yell at me when it's not
cuz I know it's not I'm getting from
this view a bit of a brainiac vibe do I
think brainiacs getting introduced in
Suicide Squad and the suicides got no
not at all but there's a little bit of
rain going on here from being honest you
know you could be like a setup for
something exactly the infection that's
on earth could that could be the thing
but then I understand Etrian
enchantresses involvement speaking of
there she is rolling her eyes of a
theory no that's not Brainiac Greg
you're so cute and handsome everyone
should follow you on twitter all right
hmm Joker not happy with one of his
outcomes again this is another this
Goldfinger proud of someone's outfit oh
no he's out one his outfits are you
really i think is like I literally the
years like seven outfits in this trailer
yeah there's shirtless there's the tux
there's this
on there's just a was the leathery one
and remember when I told you forever ago
remember the purple shirt just look at
that el Diablo shootin off some stuff
here everybody seems impressed by I'm
here on a man yeah there's another frame
of her like I was saying in the with a
party like a broken up here it looks
like is where she loses control right
again if you went back went back and
watch the original trailer this point
for Miss moon she's there and there's a
big pentagram drawn above her right and
then her eyes roll back in her head and
then here's the purple shirt again a
little bit read more burgundy here but
again this goes to I assume they they do
the assault they he zapped something dr.
Quinzel start making her crazy and then
I continues I don't know he takes her
right here to ace chemicals is what you
got oh SI haces chemicals which again
would play into the hairnet and
everything that's going on in there that
their assault day they captured her from
somewhere and then are taking her to the
chemical factory that's what I can't
connect yet you know I can't connect
that yet uh but then yeah he throws ring
here very new 52 ish right to recreate
it and then you see how autism of
exactly you see how all the colors run
out right and then get into her hair
explaining why her hair is permanently
dyed that way and bleached white mmm cuz
that you see in the next frame ride that
week that's it yeah alright those are
the colors of her hair so that you know
when he tossed her off here she jumped
and ran on her own or whatever you know
I bet Joker tossed her you know it was
to make a make another one to make a
life partner yes to make a puddin then
he just has that awesome that's why not
we go Will Smith ain't having it he's
upset proxy again this seems like we're
back to the introduction of everybody
mm-hmm all right you all want to be on
the squad or whatever you want reduced
sentences you want outcome do this yeah
maybe mr. bra shot down this plane there
we were back in the plane right or back
in the car right of course this you know
you're not happy Batman's on top of it
you some Will Smith bunch of stuff okay
so what the hell Greg now that's the
thing right is I their inner this is the
movie that introduces magic explains
what's happening right now if you look
you can see that it's going off and I
can't tell if it's making the people
around it stronger or destroying them
right is it infecting them or is it
taking away the infection whatever that
is there some kind of Ark of the
Covenant that
peers that like slammed in and then
rolled up the stairs right you figure
that's either kicking out stuff that's
making people into monsters or taking
back the stuff that made them into
monsters and it looks like in this frame
they're already monsters but you can see
there's that white stuff going on around
them as if it's taking them off but you
have you know I at this point we can
confirm that Harley katana croc we were
in a guy in a backpack general white guy
in a backpack that survived this far
into the movie in Hollywood as she does
and then here this great moon now do you
speak Latin too I do not I don't either
but I had other people on the internet
did and they translated that over there
right and what it reads too is if you
want peace prepare for war love it yeah
and this too is another thing I'm just
like the garish like artsy look at this
movie has loved it yeah yeah well yeah
that was my short take on suicides what
exactly i love how much you know cuz i
think this is one of those movies going
into it that like people don't know
these characters and don't really know
their the background or why where any of
these places are and all that stuff sure
and I mean that's why it excites again
if you want to you know hey crack was
right about something that's what I've
been saying from the jump right in the
fact that like I I said about Man of
Steel disappointed me when I first saw
it saw later on and had such low
expectations like oh this is a good
movie it's just not the movie I will i
thought i was getting and then it became
i watch the Batman V Superman trailer
I'm like oh this is the universe they're
building it was and then this when they
announced suicide spot it was like this
is gonna be the test this will be the
one that people walk out of the theater
after three cinematic movies in the DC
Universe alike I get what this universe
is it's not just sex night or being dark
and using this wash that thing like this
is the the way they want to use realism
in this world and stuff yeah then what
your magic and monsters in it definitely
excited ladies and gentlemen there's
been things you missed over on gamespot
I'm Tim Gettys this is greg miller keep
coming back and follow us at Tim Gettys
at game over gravy you should definitely
do send me your theories I want to know
what you think so yeah just say hi to me
I just like hellos he cut his beard talk
about that
you